what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
so picking up with part 2 of ultimatum
again this is like the aftermath right
like what we know so far is that magneto
is in possession of Thor's hammer and
magneto has basically instigated this
like this massive catastrophe across the
planet Earth right like he froze over
Eastern Europe he sent a massive tidal
wave against New York and essentially
flooded and destroyed the entire city
and so now we just kind of pick up with
picking up the pieces it's really it's
really what this is just kind of the
aftermath and figuring out what's going
on
however the funny thing about this is
that Peter Parker's attempts like it's
please to basically find someone to help
them out to deal with the devastation is
met with the Incredible Hulk now here's
one of the big differences between the
Incredible Hulk and the ultimate
universe and the Incredible Hulk and the
main Marvel Universe and the in the
ultimate universe The Incredible Hulk
eats people
he's as barbaric as you can imagine him
being this it's almost a little strange
cuz if you're Peter and you're in the
situation The Incredible Hulk is
unpredictable and so the Incredible Hulk
being here and helping out Peter could
easily turn into the Incredible Hulk
being here and eating Peter Parker so it
gets kind of crazy of course the
Incredible Hulk is here to help but
following this you pick up with Iron Man
basically arriving in the Triskelion
alongside or I guess really with Captain
America something else that ends up
happening here is we also pick up with
Carol Danvers now Carol Danvers in the
Ultimate Universe is really more like
Maria Hill in the main Marvel Universe
and the main Marvel Universe Carol
Danvers was originally an Air Force
pilot and then she was kind of enamored
with Marvel really more than anything
else and the idea was that she idolized
him and wanted to be like him well of
course during the battle between the
original Marvel and Annie on raagh there
was a site magnetron which basically
made that made the wishes of those come
true if they were in proximity of it or
trapped inside of it and Carol Danvers
who'd been thrown in the vicinity of
this thing wish to have the powers of
Marvel and then she became Miss Marvel
and went on to become one of the many
superheroes that existed Marvel and one
of the more prominent female figures and
the Ultimate Universe Carol Danvers is
just a SHIELD agent yes that's all she
ever really was and then from there
while she had roles in pretty
significant moments there was a story
that took place prior to this called
ultimate power and really it was it was
like a crossover between 2006 and 2008
between the ultimate universe and
squadron supreme and so it was a way to
kind of ride out Nick Fury basically to
send him over to the squadron supreme
universe and have Carol Danvers take his
place and just see what it would be like
when she's director of shield and how
fans would perceive it now the other
half of this is that relationships
between the Ultimates and Nick Fury
not that great and in fact there was a
point where the ultimate it's basically
defected and took off uh and Nick Fury
was just kind of left to his own devices
now Carol Danvers responds here is look
things don't have to be that way but of
course Tony Stark is is kind of like in
a position where he's like look this is
the last place we need to be talking
about right now like this is the last
thing we need to be discussing because
Captain America may very well not and so
that's the nature of this that's one of
the the benefits but the drawbacks of
the ultimate universe is in the main
Marvel Universe you had a lot of massive
events but because the main Marvel
Universe had been going on for you know
upwards of 40 or 50 sometimes even 60
years depending on what point what story
and how much were talking about there
could be a lot of build-up that was done
for example the death of Captain America
came out of Idi Brubaker's run and that
ran on for a few years before Captain
America actually died in the Ultimate
Universe he didn't really have that well
you did have stories like ultimate x-men
and ultimate spider-man ultimate
Fantastic Four and The Ultimates
themselves by and large the Ultimate
Universe was flying by the seat of his
pants
now the other half of this is we
actually pick up with Ben Grimm dealing
with Susan storm now again this isn't a
great big huge moment it's just the idea
of Susan storms powers kind of
subconsciously growing and expanding and
having an influence even when she's
unconscious and this really hits my way
of the fact that like she makes the
floor invisible she ends up sending Ben
Grimm flying into a wall different
things like that it's nothing too major
really the big thing that kind of comes
out of this or at least one of the big
things that kind of come out of this is
one Reed Richards has taken name where
the Submariner captive and two he's
actually grabbed by Doctor Doom and the
reason why is because remember much like
the main Marvel Universe Doctor Doom
holds absolute allegiance to Latveria he
is that beholden to them Doctor Doom
basically hits up Reed Richards and says
look man you got princess power from the
squadron supreme universe she can
basically grab Nick Fury we can figure
out what's going on you know pull our
resources together or what have you but
like this is not a namor the sub-mariner
thing like Reed Richards believes it is
it's Magneto now Reed Richards knows
this because Charles Xavier uses
telepathy to tell him that but this is
one of the weird things about Reed so
when the Ultimate Universe
Reed is a lot younger than he is in the
main Marvel Universe and that was
because it was designed to basically
tell a story from the Tommy was a kid up
until the time that he was an adult but
because of the fact that he's so young
he doesn't quite have the wisdom and
experience of older Reed Richards and
this has been met with mixed reviews
there are people who love the idea of a
younger really that like a younger Reed
is more interesting there's a lot more a
lot more storytelling that can be told
with a younger version of Reed but there
are people who also kind of look at that
and say yeah but I prefer experience
Reed rich
like I prefer the one who's seen some
things who's been around it's like the
debate between new 52 Superman versus
classic Superman it really kind of
depends on where you picked up but the
fact remains here that we end up picking
up with for now this is the cool thing
about Thor remember when it comes to the
idea of the alternate universe and when
it comes to the whole notion of like
various superheroes it is designed to be
more tangible and a lot more grounded
however because Thor is rooted in in
mythology because Thor is such a
prominent character even if not you know
that popular in terms of comic book
sales because he's so well known in in
Marvel Comics you can't really mess with
it too much
and so what Marvel did and we covered
this of me in our video on the the
origin of ultimate fort what Marvel did
as I said okay so this version of Thor
originates on Asgard but was basically
banished to earth much like he was the
main Marvel Universe the difference here
is that Asgard was destroyed in the
1930s after Thor was banished so he
could basically never go back and so the
result is that Thor initially believed
himself to be human and then ultimately
you know as time progressed began it
could become aware of what it was that
he was about but again that's kind of
how these these cool things fit in is
because we're he when he basically
arrives at the Statue of Liberty on
Staten Island and finds that Valkyrie
seems to be dead while it is his love
interest he basically ends up like
traveling to the realm of hella
traveling through the realm of Hell
itself and in turn like essentially
trying to get her soul back saying look
like I want I want my kid like I want
her character to return now this is
actually homage to the original four
stories by Stan Lee and Jack Kirby right
especially tales of Asgard by Jack Kirby
and the reason why was because there was
a point where the character of SIF who
was a love interest of Thor at the time
was actually kidnapped and of course you
know Thor went on to rescue her which
made him worthy to lift his hammer for
the first time in the main Marvel
Universe so this is kind of a tribute to
that kind of a throwback to those old
stories but how his response is if you
can defeat my army then you will get
basically like you'd like you will get
Valkyrie back though there will be a
price to be paid or something along
those lines now in the midst of this
whole fight he's met with the arrival of
Captain America so of course the
indication here is that Steve Rogers is
actually dead and his soul is trapped in
the realm of hell it's kind of crazy
when you when you get down to this whole
thing but from here we basically pick up
with Hank Pym trying to find Janet Van
Dyne and this is probably one of the
most screwed up parts of the story and I
don't really know why this is in here
it's pretty well but you have Hawkeye
who of course is enhanced eyesight will
allow him to you know spot Jan where as
Hank Pym may not have been able to pick
her up but where Hawkeye basically
locates where he
she is and then jumps down and starts
you know sifting through the rubble to
try to find her what he ends up
discovering is that the blob his action
is actually eating jam-band on it he's
actually consuming her it's almost like
something out of Marvel Zombies
it's pretty messed up like it's it's
pretty screwed up ah probably one of the
weirdest things it's not as weird as
Scarlet Witch and Quicksilver getting it
on like being lovers in the alternate
universe which yes they are brother and
sister and yes it is weird but like like
you know it's not as weird as that you
know but it's it's still pretty messed
up and it's still pretty screwed up
right so from here we pick up with
magneto traveling to go meet with
Charles Xavier now this is one of the
coolest parts of the story magneto in
the alternate universe is vastly
different in so many different ways from
his main Marvel Universe counterpart
right I think this version of magneto in
the Ultimate Universe is really more
akin to like classic Magneto but even
still darker so in the main Marvel
Universe magneto is waxed and waned over
the years right like he was originally a
friend of Xavier and the two of them
basically had a philosophical split in
terms of how to deal with humanity and
it's you know perception of mutant kind
this led to them basically becoming
enemies but there was always a kind of
respect between the two of them and even
even despite what rifts were there there
was a time where magneto actually led
the x-men and he led the new mutants
following that he basically de Partie
went back to being a villain again and
and it really just kind of went back and
forth but there was always a grudging
respect between the two and it was
always the idea that magneto was more of
a of a savior slash Messiah than someone
who wanted to like impose his will in a
dark and terrible way in the Ultimate
Universe it's the exact opposite magneto
was far more cynical he does not trust
humanity in any form or fashion in this
when magneto shows up Xavier is like
what was only ever a matter of time
before I saw you like it was only a
matter of time before you got here and
it was kind of interesting because here
like you basically have two guys who are
indeed mortal enemies like there is no
respect between the two they hate the
other and where Xavier looks at Magneto
and says the fact that you would do
something like this is believable the
fact that you would use such power to
basically reverse the magnetic poles to
instigate this massive global
catastrophe is believable you have
really just gone too far like you're
really off the edge and so the response
of Xavier is I will dedicate every
minute I will dedicate every ounce of my
strength to seeing your destruction
up to this point I've just been a
roadblock I've stood in the way after
this I will be the cement wall that will
keep you from going forward and that's
kind of the cool thing because Magneto's
response is when God didn't
what it was that he created he wiped it
all away in 40 days and 40 nights I'll
do it in three like I mean it's just
it's that dark like it's it's that
that's screwed up but we're again we're
we're xavier kind of responds by saying
no one's ever gonna see you as a messiah
no one's ever gonna see you as a person
who's leading mutants into a greater
future they're gonna see you as a dark
and terrible ruler the response of
magneto is if all you're ever gonna do
is stand in my way then i'll remove you
from the equation and he breaks the neck
of charles xavier magneto kills xavier
would that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here two comments explained make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
cliffhangers peace